so just to start out I think I should
definitely make a a personal statement
and that is that my goal is not to
offend anyone um you know I was a
practitioner I was sucked into yoga I
was devoted uh to the practice I didn't
understand that there was a spiritual
component to it I thought that it was
just exercise I didn't see a problem as
a Christian doing it and I didn't see it
as a problem if you were secular and you
weren't Christian I just didn't see that
there was anything to be worrisome about
and so it's really important that I that
I make that personal statement that this
is not a a picking on um yoga or its
roots of Hinduism this is just more of
an
informational um uh package so that
people who are partaking in it
understand what they're stepping into
because it's not what they're being told
there's a lot of undisclosed information
that you need to know and I believe in a
God that practices informed consent what
does the word yoga mean very fundamental
and very important it means yoke but the
symbolic implication is to be yolked
with Brahman have you ever seen somebody
sitting in the Lotus position with their
hands like thish the people think that's
a harmless way to sit and and just calm
your mind but that's what's called a
mudra am mudra is a symbolic G gesture
with the hand or with the body that
represents the spiritual concept the
forefinger represents your individual
soul called Atman in uh in Sanskrit and
the thumb represents Brahman the
oversoul that impersonal life force when
you curl your finger around and touch it
like that it is an invocation you are
invoking Brahman to manifest completely
in your life so that you become God
manifested In the Flesh so to speak for
people who don't understand mantras are
incantations to the spirits a mantra is
saying I want to yoke my spirit with you
Brahman and any other deity that I you
know subscribe to that I want to worship
there are dozens of different
expressions of yoga and Kundalini Yoga
is supposed to be an amalgamation of all
of them from haa yoga which is the
fundamental kind of yoga that deals with
ASAS which are physical exercises and PR
Y which are breathing exercises people
think those are harmless and unspiritual
but they are the third and fourth step
of eight steps that are supposed to lead
you to somati which is a Hindu term for
an enlightened state so what they call
samade or they call Mosa it's like
you're being liberated from your mind
and you're being united with the
ultimate mhm reality which is BR
so in other words you're being possessed
mhm yeah um and then here we are New
York Times bestseller sad Guru says
kundalini's mind altering and you know
he says that it's it's it it's able to
change the perceptions and change the
chemicals in your your brain as your eye
is awakened there is a link for anyone
who's interested to see what Kundalini
looks like it looks like demonic
possession like what you would think
like the Exorcist So holy yoga we're
going to watch the little video it's
just a little commercial of theirs we
are
Serenity we are
peace we are
Community we are yoga and we are Jesus I
am Holy yoga I am Holy yoga I am Holy
yoga I am Holy yoga I am Holy yoga We
Are Holy
[Music]
yoga you know I really hope this doesn't
anyone but this is just how I see it how
it's kind of like contradicting when I
see holy yoga and knowing the meaning of
yoga and what it means in a religious
sense that's like saying holy Voodoo
yeah good point it's like why and I get
um maybe the underlying reason why
they're doing it um exercise or or
relief of stress but call it something
else is what I'm thinking at the end of
the day exactly yeah coin a new phrase
or something do you know something that
hit me was um you know I started in
martial artarts and Eastern mysticism
and taii and all that stuff and was in
it for 25 years and when I began back in
the early
80s yoga was like an extreme you only
saw
esoteric hippie you know it was only for
the extreme you never could imagine like
you said you never say Voodoo and holy
or it's Christian Voodoo we've changed
it so for me you know there's questions
there but you're still like wait a
minute that's like saying Christian
pornography you how do you do that we
live in a world where we are literally
putting Christian on everything yeah and
how many stories have we heard where
people say you know I did it because I
had a back injury I was stretching and
then people said hey you can meditate it
just helps relieve stress and the next
thing you know they're you know
communicating with ascended masters and
they're full on in the New Age yes so
it's this slippery slope in in the
beginning people are saying oh it's not
spiritual it's just a stretching but
I've heard it over and over and over it
always not always but a lot of times
goes that direction if you tell a devote
Hindu I'm just doing yoga for stretching
I'm not in Hinduism uh I don't practice
yoga for the
spirituality uh the Hindu may get
offended because yoga is a Hindu ritual
wow I mean I I we've we've made this
comparison before but I guess if
somebody was praying but like I'm not
praying to your God you know it I could
understand that if you're doing that
activity that's typically associated
with that spiritual exercise hey could I
get baptized at your church oh you
accepted Christ no I just I just want to
do the baptism thing I just want to go
under the water yeah that's exactly
correct uh we can take an instance from
Ezekiel um chapter 8 uh where um the
prophet Ezekiel is taken by the law to
different compartments in the sanctuary
and there uh God shows Ezekiel that the
Believers the 25 Israelites men they had
their backs to God's Temple but they
were B to the sun yeah and God calls
that as the greatest Abomination and
these are believers in the church
Sanctuary but and they're not chanting
all they're doing is bowing prostrate is
the right uh uh uh word um and um so if
you look for the word the root word
there for Bowing it says to prostrate
and so they were bowing to Sun Su n and
God calls as the greatest Abomination
today it is called in the US it's called
Sun salutation yeah so the actual word
is Surya namaskara suryya means Sun
namaskara actually means worship so
people are worshiping the Sun the same
exact thing that happened in the time of
Ezekiel is happening today in the US in
Christianity chanting the same words
10,000 times that's very mechanical
that's like inserting a program on your
computer that's supposed to result in
the right kind of output right um uh
well Jesus even taught use not vain
repetitions like the Heathen
do because right now we're having a
conversation and if I was to sit here
and say the same five word statement 200
times how long would you keep me on the
right you would exit stage left real
quick it's because you're intelligent
human beings and the way for us to
connect relationally is is to express a
flow of thought in a communicable way uh
from Heart to Heart from mind to mind
well communication with God is the same
and I tell people that chanting a mantra
is an insult to the intelligence of God
if God was just an impersonal force it
would make sense
10,000 times and you can manipulate the
force to do what you want it to do it's
all mechanical but if God is a personal
God which he is then that's not going to
get you to the first base right because
you approach him with your heart with an
intelligent flow of language that he
fully comprehends and prayer is dialogue
it's not monologue I don't see how one
Doctrine can have all of these different
things unless you're trying to catch
you're casting a broad net and you're
trying to catch everybody yeah so in
other words it's basically relativism
you know universalism too whatever is
God to you is God to you who am I to say
right and the God in Me salutes the god
in you so they Namaste exactly so who is
the Supreme Being in Hinduism and you've
heard me refer to him already Brahman
and they call him the Ultimate Reality
they say that he's the cosmos the
universe but he also comes with other
deities but the top three deities are
the ones that you hear about the most
because it's a way to con convert
Christians mhm and so they talk about um
let's see uh there's the three the top
three are Brahma the sustainer Vishnu um
or sorry Creator Brahman the sustainer
bishnu and the Destroyer Shiva we pride
ourselves when I say we I say generally
as a culture pride ourselves on our
scientific mindset which which is based
on uh uh experimentation observation and
then uh you line up the criteria and if
it doesn't fulfill the criteria you toss
something out uh and so we we are very
good at Discerning or try to be very
good at Discerning correct from
incorrect um assumptions about different
aspects of Nature and life Etc uh why
then do we toss out any kind of
discrimination when it comes to
spiritual matters and think that that's
bigotry and that's uh and and that's um
un uh unfair to those that Embrace that
worldview and we've got to say you're
your truth is your truth and my truth is
myth truth is not subjective truth is
objective it's the same for everybody
that's right whether we accept or not
when I was more involved in yoga they
talked about Jesus too and they're like
yeah he's you know like there's ways to
see him right you know like he's a great
spiritual teacher he is the Son of God
he's one of them you know
um there's Krishna and Buddha along with
him and you're the Son of God right and
I actually went to school with a bunch
of Christians and they did not come out
of it Christian um like some of them
still say that they like pray to Jesus
but like they pray to him like as a
spirit guide along with these other gods
um so like it really does affect you
like I am guarantee you these Christians
did not go here thinking that they were
going to give up this Faith yeah I mean
if you believe in Christianity then it
wouldn't make sense to practice yoga um
that's what's even more ironic about
Christian Yoga it's like why do we have
to put the word Christian with it if
there was nothing wrong with it I mean I
just don't say Christian pickle
ball like I'm not arguing for pickle why
you got to attach Christian in front of
it because you're trying to re make
sense of why you're doing this thing
that's like not compatible what would
you say to somebody that's like
practicing yoga but is caught in that
world of I'm a Christian but I still
like the act of of yoga how would you
how would you begin to give them a
practical advice on how to unravel that
sure if you're doing yoga for health as
a Christian then Bible is your book the
people who live longest and strong they
follow the LW of Health from the
Bible we don't have a community of yogis
living 100 years any in this world it
has never been in the past to my
knowledge whereas you have a community
of people in lalinda California who live
100 years and they don't practice yoga
they practice what the Bible teaches for
health so that is my advice or
suggestion or recommendation rather for
people who are looking for health next
please also research uh on um the side
effects of yoga people will have side
effects of yoga uh usually the people
that I have come across that uh that
practice yoga they have gut issues oh
then they also have anger problems
especially the yogis who are into
meditation they have anger
problems and I have not so far have not
met any um yoga practitioner the ones
who do
meditation Eastern meditation say that
oh I have so much joy in my heart mm in
fact they have always said the opposite
that they have no peace in their
[Music]
lives and so please do your thorough
research don't just uh practice anything
not only yoga anything for that matter
just because it giving you it's giving
you health benefits just like you read
ingredients before you eat yeah you have
to read the ingredients of your
spiritual or physical practice also what
does it entail uh ingredients in yoga is
Hinduism uh Hindu teaching ancient
teaching that you are sure you are gods
and you will not surely die and also
yoga will eventually separate the
practitioner from Christ so yoga
initially will give you benefits as you
keep on doing it it will become a
spiritual exercise it will and you won't
even know it's happening and eventually
your conscience will be silenced and you
will be separated from the Holy Spirit
which will lead you to commit the UN
aable sin it is that serious
[Music]